[Musica]
sono un economista uno storico economico
che si occupa di benessere e come tale
ho pensato di cominciare questa
conversazione dal pil prodotto interno
lordo
perché il pil degli italiani è un po che
da delle preoccupazioni lo guardiamo ho
smesso di crescere addirittura si è
fermato è andato indietro e adesso non
riprende ed ho un po di prospettiva
storica a questa analisi perché trarrà
vantaggio dalla grande quantità di dati
che è stata elaborata dagli storici
economici negli ultimi due tre decenni
quindi per raccontare un pochino la
storia e avere beneficio di salire un po
sulla montagna a guardare i contorni
della foresta anziché stare solo dentro
la foresta allora la domanda che mi
pongo è giusta tutta questa attenzione
questa preoccupazione che abbiamo per il
pil
la risposta è si la risposta a breve
però sono qui per dire ma sì ma c'è
anche un ma che credo che meriti un po
di attenzione allora cominciò dicendo
che naturalmente noi diamo per scontato
che ci sia la crescita alla crescita
economica
ma questo è un fatto storicamente
nuovissimo cercherò di mostrarvi qualche
qualche numero ma insomma la christie
con omega è una creatura moderna per
milioni di anni
l'uomo non è stato in grado di
migliorare le proprie condizioni di vita
non in maniera permanente non in maniera
significativa
poi è successo qualcosa lo sanno anche i
miei figli a scuole media lecce ormai
c'è stata quella che il premio nobel per
l'economia 2015 angus deaton ha chiamato
la grande fuga scrivendo questo libro
bellissimo grande fuga da che cosa dalla
miseria dalla morte prematura ed è una
grande fuga che come sappiamo tutti ha
cominciato con il gruppo la rivoluzione
industriale in inghilterra alla fine
ottocento e poi piano piano tutti i
paesi hanno
cercato di imitare questo modello
vi faccio vedere in questa diapositiva
la grande fuga degli italiani questi
sono dati stimati recentemente in cui
abbiamo sull'asse orizzontale il tempo
faccio cominciare il grafico insomma
parecchio indietro sarei potuto andare
ancora più indietro per arrivare grosso
modo al 17 marzo 1861 quando è stato
proclamato il regno d'italia nel asse
verticale metto il prodotto interno
lordo pil e quello che scopro scopro che
queste ci sono state un paio di guerra
mondiale che lo so noi siamo qui c'è una
piccola non abbiamo ancora il pil del
nuovo presidente perché non è ancora
dicembre quindi dobbiamo scheda nato
quello che si vede da quei una cosa che
è quella che dicevo poco fa la normalità
è stata la stagnazione
e poi c'è stato un balzo un grandissimo
balzo straordinario che quando lo
guardiamo con misurato nel metro della
storia è avvenuto in un tempo
rapidissimo perché questa linea avrei
potuto portarla indietro fino ai tempi
di cesare non sarebbe cambiato granché
quindi abbiamo in una diapositiva nella
nostra storia velocissimo un progresso
su cui nessuno scommetteva rapidissimo
velocissimo ma molto molto limitato nel
tempo e poi come vedete c'è un
preoccupante
diciamo accenno di decrescita la stessa
fuga è avvenuta in altre dimensioni del
benessere questa è la speranza di vita
alla nascita abbiamo lo stesso tempo
nell'asse orizzontale e abbiamo questa
straordinaria capacità degli italiani
che sono diventati il popolo più longevo
nel mondo secondo solo al giappone
quindi un'altra bella pagina di storia
c'è un ma e qui inizia il ma se questo
non fosse questo è l'unica cosa che
compare nei libri che abbiamo non c'è
altro finora nella storiografia italiana
ma anche a questa riflessione la storia
crescita economica non è un processo
neutrale non beneficia tutti non sempre
non nella stessa misura e quindi mi
chiedo cosa sappiamo
beh questo è un grafico che dimostra che
se guardo
di nuovo al caso dell'italia nel corso
di 150 anni l'italia è riuscita al netto
dell'inflazione di queste cose riuscite
ad aumentare il proprio reddito di circa
12 volte pro capite se guardo l'italia
del nord e guardo l'italia del sud
ottengono mary diversi al centro nord si
è cresciuti molto di più che non al
mezzogiorno
questo è un esempio di grande fuga in
cui alcuni sono andati più veloci di
altri possono chiedere di più e gli
storici economici e chiedere a livello
di regione io vengo da modena sono molto
non è un caso che ci sia questa
diapositiva l'emilia romagna è il paese
che è la regione che è cresciuta più
rapidamente capite per farla breve è una
fuga selettiva non tutti non sempre non
nella stessa misura si può fare molto
meglio di questo però è difficile se io
voglio capire come analista del
benessere a chi si distribuisce il
beneficio della crescita
dovrei conoscere entrare nelle case
delle persone conoscere viaggiare
indietro nel tempo conoscere i redditi o
le spese di tutti e poi cercare di
seguire l'andamento questo problema
difficile perché l'istat colleziona i
bilanci delle famiglie a partire l'istat
nasce nel 1926 i primi bilanci li
abbiamo per il 1968
quindi come si fa a ripercorrere a
capire la nostra storia per un periodo
in cui non c'era neanche i bilanci si
raccolgono e quello che ho fatto per 20
anni
bilanci di famiglie gli italiani come
tanti altri coppie hanno ottenuto
contabilità in vent'anni ne ho raccolti
oltre ventimila vi faccio vedere che
cosa viene fuori
questa è una storia che dobbiamo
sovrapporre a quella che vi ho fatto
vedere del pil che aumenta questa è la
storia della distribuzione della
disuguaglianza del reddito
ciò sempre il tempo nell'asse
orizzontale ma nell asse verticale o un
indice di gini è un indice che molto
alto quando c'è molta disuguaglianza e
diminuisce quando c'è molta
uguaglianza troviamo una storia
bellissima
gli italiani sono riusciti a fuggire
dalla miseria e sono riusciti
coniugando a questa grande crescita una
capacità di condividere di distribuire
perché la disuguaglianza nel lungo
periodo è diminuita ma vedete che
qualcosa si è rotto qualcosa si è
inceppato intorno agli inizi degli anni
90 questo è un indicatore di sintesi che
ci dà comunque una pagina di cui essere
molto fieri una crescita e di questo
tipo di evidenzia lo sappiamo per molti
pochi paesi nel mondo oggi in questo
siamo pionieri e scriviamo una bella
pagina di storia possiamo fare ancora di
più vi faccio vedere questo grafico e
tecnico ma vale la pena perché mi ha
insegnato tantissimo il grafico funziona
così questa volta
considero un periodo i primi 50 anni
l'italia liberale e mi chiedo
prendiamo tutte le persone che hanno
vissuto in quell'elenco intorno di
secolo e nel lasso orizzontale metto la
popolazione ordinandola dai poveracci ai
ricchi quindi o i poveri classe media e
mezzo e poi oi ricchi sulla destra nell
asse verticale misura di quanto è
cresciuto il reddito durante questi
cinquanta anni la linea rossa mi dice
guardate in media durante questi in
media ma l'italiano medio non esiste
siamo per questo in media è cresciuto un
po meno dell'uno per cento
erano anni in cui l'italia non aveva
ancora preso la traiettoria della
rivoluzione industriale
il grafico cosa ci dice ci dice
esattamente chi ha vinto chi ha perso
chi è sopra la linea vuol dire che è
cresciuto più della media vuol dire che
in un modo o nell'altro è riuscito a
beneficiare più della crescita economica
e che non gli altri da questo grafico
impariamo che in questo periodo di tempo
essere molto poveri qui a sinistra
essere molto ricchi non è stato il
migliore dei periodi tutti questi
stavano sotto la linea rossa
qui è nata la classe media si alimenta e
in particolare la upper middle class la
parte un po più alta
il tempo corre questo grafico e lo
possiamo ripetere ero fatto con tutti
questi bilanci di famiglia o una curva
per l'italia liberale o un'altra curva
per l'italia fascista o un'altra curva
per gli anni difficili che sono seguiti
allo shock petrolifero fino alla crisi
del 1992 e poi ai giorni nostri
ora i miei studenti li affliggono i
dettagli perché e percome qui c'è lo
sono rimasti quattro minuti cosa devo
dire
impariamo una cosa importantissima la
crescita ha avvolti molto diverse
la storia non si ripete mai in un
qualche modo i vincitori ei vinti
dipendono dai periodi storici è una
pessima idea essere poveri in questo
periodo in cui viviamo noi ora vedete
che qui più si e poveri più si allontani
dalla crescita e media e in più siamo in
terreno negativo prodotto idea una
classe media che si difende i super
ricchi
la natura e la qualità della crescita è
molto diverso quindi la crescita per sé
è molto importante ma naturalmente non
basta per trarre e avere un senso un
giudizio della distribuzione dei
benefici da cui una prima considerazione
che ci dice che la crescita economica è
una cosa necessaria ma in nessun modo
per nessun motivo sufficiente per
garantire benessere di tutti ammesso che
condividiamo naturalmente questa questo
valore questo è l'ultimo grafico ed è
bellissimo
ho messo sempre il tempo nell'asse
orizzontale poi ho fatto una cosa
complicata mi sono chiesto se io prendo
la prima decade 1861 1870 qual è il
paese nel mondo che cresce più in fretta
durante quei dieci anni e poi mi sono
chiesto e qual è il paese peggiore è la
risposta è il paese peggiore la cina il
paese migliore e la nuova zelanda
ho fatto questo per tutti i decenni
quindi ho trovato non ci interessa
niente adesso sapere chi è il più bravo
ho trovato la linea dei migliori e la
linea dei peggiori durante gli ultimi
150 anni
questo disegna un cono che è la grande
divergenza è questo grande processo di
crescita diseguale del mondo
e poi ho messo dentro la nostra
italietta che la che la linea rossa qui
scoprendo una cosa per i figli terribile
l'italia è il paese peggiore nel mondo
durante la decade 2000 2010 in quanto
tassi di crescita del reddito pro capite
questo mi lascia un un secondo messaggio
la crescita è molto importante perché
qui stiamo dicendo che stiamo facendo
non solo male ma particolarmente male e
stiamo imparando che la la la crescita
può poi interrompersi sul serio e forse
alla parola crisi
io ho usato una parola diversa qui no
scusate dove ho usato la parola declino
che è una cosa molto più seria la
venezia del trecento sono culturale
sparisco e tornano magari però dopo
qualche secolo
mi avvio a concludere bisogna avere
paura di questo declino
sì ma questo è un vestito con cui ho
aperto angus deaton dice però state
stiamo ragionevolmente tranquilli
science riley works la tecnologia e la
scienza ci salveranno garantiranno che
in una maniera nell'altra supereremo
anche questo avremo un nuovo giolitti
avremo nuove inaudi avremo lo so però la
tecnologia ci salverà possibile che gli
italiani che hanno fatto così ma non
capiscono questo certo che no lo capiamo
eppure siamo nella posizione che vi ho
fatto vedere poco farlo
allora ciò solo due diapositive per i
due minuti che mi restano la prima è
questa la scienza e la tecnologia non
sono fenomeni neutrali implicano e
comportano molte tensioni all'interno di
una società ci sono settori che
spariscono ci sono settori che esplodono
una società deve volere questo
cambiamento deve saperlo gestire questa
tensione se le disuguaglianze aumentano
troppo il tessuto sociale
inizia a sfilacciarsi ci sono le persone
vanno alle urne e si fa partono dei
meccanismi che possono non rendere
possibile l'adozione della tecnologia
anche se lì fuori una società può non
riuscire a fare questo social
capabilities
è un'espressione usata da uno studioso
che si chiama abramowitz libri
bellissimi ha scritto e adesso unisco
tutti i pezzi per lasciarmi amareggiati
temo perché non c'è la lieto fine
allora quando aveva funzionare ecco
allora il ritratto del nostro paese
visto nella sua intera storia post
unitaria è quello di un paese che ha
smesso di crescere per un periodo che
non conoscevano abbia mai conosciuto
prima
sono 25 anni che paese difficoltà e
abbia e osserviamo indicatori come la
disuguaglianza della crescita e la
povertà in rapido aumento
quando questo accade se hanno delle
conseguenze che non sanno più a che fare
con l'economia ma con la società
iniziamo a sviluppare dei valori
l'intolleranza la chiusura la ricerca
della rendita
la paura che porta ad avere anziché
competizione chiusura questi valori sono
quelli che inibiscono la social
capabilities che impediscono a una
società alla classe dirigente di dire il
cambiamento lo dobbiamo gestire ma è
l'unica salvezza per continuare a
crescere ea trasmettere benessere ai
figli e alle generazioni
che vengono no soccer cup ability no
science no technology non riusciremo ad
adottare a stare ad accomodare i
cambiamenti che richiede l'innovazione
scientifica e se non c'è social
capabilities
non c'è il principale motore che è
quello che ha tenuto fuori il mondo
dalla povertà
fino ad oggi che la tecnologia la mia
conclusione è crescita va bene
suggerisco di alla classe dirigente a
cui apparteniamo noi tutti di introdurre
tre altre parole tre altri indicatori da
monitorare disuguaglianza le persone lo
fanno perché hanno un po di allergie a
questa cosa bene o male che sia ma
povertà
gli italiani porta non interessa molto e
guardando avanti le tre parole con cui
vi lascio con cui credo
ed è ciò che cerco di spiegare agli
studenti i miei figli a cui voglio bene
le tre parole sono cultura crescita
naturalmente ma che sia una crescita di
tipo inclusivo perché queste
disuguaglianze non ci portano a non ci
consentiranno di continuare la marcia
verso il progresso grazie
[Applauso]